[Applause]
to Texas back in bama territory viewers
from the pocket now he'll Loft one
downfield a ton of air running under
[Applause]
arms down
see how he feels okay I've got him where
I want him let's put it up in the air
one-on-one against the freshman and he
goes to one of the top receivers in the
country Worthy
play face viewers slant touchdown
Mitchell what a response by Texas it's
really showing tonight
Lewis in the pocket watching down field
Mitchell touchdown Texas
receivers underneath the impact the
safety so he knows again we saw this
earlier on the left side this time they
go to the right creates a one-on-one
match